In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Lureeding from the Sinaxadion for July 10th, on which we commemorate, our venerable father
Antony, founder of the Lavra, of the Kiev Caves, and the father of Russian monasticism,
our Holy Father Antony was born in the year 983 in Lubek in the Chernugov region, and received
the name Antipas at Holy Baptism. Desiring from his earliest years to consecrate himself
to God, he left his homeland and, passing through Constantinople, went to the Holy Mountain
of Athos. After having visited the monasteries where the angelic life of the monks inclined
his heart the more to love for God, he was received in the monastery of Esfigmenu and became
a disciple of Abbot Thokdistus, a man of outstanding virtue. Doing violence to himself
in all things in order to observe the commandments to perfection, Antony was the joy of the brethren.
After several years Thokdistus, after a divine revelation, sent his disciple back to Russia,
going to him, Antony, go to Russia and become there an example and guide to the people. May
the blessing of the Holy Mountain go with you. Arriving in Kiev in the year 1013, he visited
the monasteries of the town but did not find the place he was seeking. Going into the neighbouring
hills, he found, at Bedestevil, a cave earlier hallowed out by the Varengians and settled there
to live in Askecies and Prayer. After the death of St. Vladimir, his son, the godless Sveta Polk,
ascended the throne of Kiev. In order to secure all power, he killed his brothers, the holy princes,
Boris and Gleb, and unleashed a blood-thirsty persecution against the men of God. Seeing this
spilling of blood, St. Antony left once again for the Holy Mountain. Having, however, tasted the honey
of Hisikia, he was given Thokdistus blessing to withdraw some distance from Esfigmenu to Mount Samaria.
Prince Janoslav, the friend of God, having defeated Sveta Polk in the year 1019, gathered together
the monks who had been dispersed and had many churches built. A priest from Bedestovil,
called Iladion, famed for his Askecies and knowledge of the scriptures, then went to settle on the
wooded hill near the Neeper, where the monastery of the caves stands today. He hallowed himself out
a small cave there and engaged in spiritual combat alone with God until the day that he was elevated
to the Episcopal Sea of Kiev in the year 1051. At the same time, Thokdistus received a revelation
to send Antony back to Russia, and God guided the saints' steps to the very cave where Iladion had
lived. The place which reminded him of Athos appealed to him, and he asked God that the blessing
of the Holy Mountain should rest on that spot. He lived there in strict Askecies, having prayer as his
unceasing work. He ate only bread and drink water every two or three days, and, when he was wrapped,
in holy contemplation, he could remain a week without food or drink. His angelic way of life
soon became known to the local people, and a great many devout men began to visit him.
Some asked to remain with him to delight in his teaching. Firstly, the priest Nikon, and then
St. Thildosius, aged 23 at that time. St. Antony's fame, having spread throughout Russia, Prince
Isia's love of Kiev who had succeeded Yaroslav in 1054, came in person for his blessing, accompanied by
his whole court. This brought new disciples to the cave, among them blessed Barlam, son of the boyar,
John, and Ephrem the unique, adopted son of the grand prince. When John discovered that his son had
become a monk, he went to the cave in a fury, scattered the monks and seizing his son, tore off his
monastic habit, and forced him to return to his palace. On his part, grand prince Isia's love,
ordered that St. Nikon, who had concert Ephrem, be arrested, and threatened to destroy the cave,
and throw the fathers into prison. St. Antony and his disciples fled to another place,
but the prince's wife begged Isia's love to stop persecution for fear that divine wrath
would fall on him, as had been the case in her native Poland when her father had driven out the monks.
The prince calmed down and sent messengers to recall St. Antony. Shortly after his return to the cave,
God, having heard his servants prayer, gathered together the dispersed disciples, who were joined
by new brethren, soon becoming twelve in number, as were the apostles around the Lord.
The cave, having become too cramped, it was enlarged, and then a chapel was made inside it,
with cells round about. St. Antony, whose soul was always desirous of solitude, gathered his disciples
together one day, and said to them, My children, you know that the Lord has brought us together,
here, as first fruits of the blessing of our whole people. You are the blessing of the holy mountain,
and of the most holy mother of God. It is this blessing that I leave you for a heritage.
So live together. I will leave you an abit, as it is right for me to withdraw into solitude.
I will, though, stay here, and will, as long as I live, remain your spiritual father.
He appointed Barlam to be abbot and withdrew to a neighboring hill,
where he hollowed out a cave. The community, having grown rapidly under the wise guidance of Saint
Barlam, it was necessary to build a bigger church outside the cave. The brethren first built a church
dedicated to the Dormition of the Mother of God, above their first cave. Shortly afterwards,
the Grand Prince, having appointed Barlam abbot of the monastery of Saint Demetrios,
which he had founded, the brethren went to ask Saint Antony to indicate who should be the new
superior, and Saint Thildosios was chosen for his obedience, gentleness, and humility.
Under his direction, the community grew from 20 to over 100 monks, and it became a matter of
urgency to build a monastery to shelter them. Saint Antony sent one of the brethren to Prince
Ezeoslav to ask him to give them ownership of the entire hill and the necessary funds for the building.
The brethren, under the direction of Saint Thildosios, built a vast wooden church and a sufficient
number of cells. They then left their caves to live in the monastery, which, from then on,
bore the name of the Lavra, of the Kiev caves. Through Saint Antony's prayers, Thildosios
made the acquaintance of the monk Michael of the studio who was visiting Russia. He questioned him
about the liturgical and monastic practice in that famous monastery. And, having later received
Saint Ephrem's tipicon of the studio, he made it the rule followed from that time onwards in the
monasteries of Russia. During this time, Saint Antony, aspiring in his cave to new spiritual heights,
acquired abundant gifts of prescience and healing. He blessed poisonous plants, making potions of them
that he gave to the sick to drink, and they were healed at once, of all their ills.
The man of God predicted to Prince Ezeoslav of Kiev, Sviatoslav of Chernegov,
and Sevalod of Peryoslavl, the defeat that they were to suffer on the altar against the
paloptions, who would then invade Russian lands, plundering the towns and taking innumerable captives.
The people of Kiev urged Ezeoslav to resist the barbarians, but he dared not risk a further defeat.
He was dethroned and fled to Poland, where, after having assembled an army,
he succeeded seven months later in reconquering the town in the year 1069.
One of the princes' close advisers then accused Saint Antony of sympathizing with the usurper,
Sesslav, and this made Ezeoslav furious with the man of God.
About this time, Saint Antony had been caring for Isaac the recluse, who had been tricked by the demon.
The enemy of the human race, seeing himself vanquished by the saint's prayers,
then incited the prince to drive Antony out of his kingdom to put a stop to Isaac's healing.
Prince Sviatoslav of Chernegov, having learned of the resentment his brother was nourishing towards
the saint, invited Saint Antony into his principality. Antony chose there a place a little
withdrawn from the city and hollowed out himself a cave, where he returned untroubled to his ascetic life.
Ezeoslav had, however, realized that the saint was innocent, and understanding the demon's
ruse sent emissaries to Antony, begging him to return to his spiritual flock.
After his return to Kiev, Saint Antony redoubled his ascetic endeavors. His days and nights were
an unceasing struggle against the prince of darkness, for the victory of the light of Christ.
When he had blessed the place where the monastery's church was to be built,
and when, at his prayers, Masons from Constantinople had arrived, Saint Antony
sensing that the hour of his departure from this life was at hand, called the brethren together
and consoled them, telling them that after his departure, he would not abandon the monastery,
but would keep watch over them for the rest of time,
delighting in the progress of all his spiritual children, and praying that they receive mercy on the day
of judgment. Having lived for sixteen years in his second cave, Saint Antony, who had become
patriarch of the monks of Russia, as Saint Antony the Great had been in former times in Egypt,
fell asleep in the Lord on the 10th of July in the year 1073, at the age of 90.
His body was placed in his cave, and as the saint had desired to remain hidden from the eyes of
men during his life. So his precious relics, there in his cave beneath the great monastery,
remained inaccessible. Every time there was an attempt to dig into the cave to find them,
a fire flared up from the earth and burned the full hearty searchers. Although hidden,
they nonetheless continued to be a source of healing and blessing to the faithful.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.